so we got a lot of conventions here how
about going from luxury dog washes to
vegan pet food the latest in all things
pets being featured at the event called
super zoo our bianca holman live at
mandalay bay to show us around we've had
some cool stuff already what else do you
have there bianca
hey good morning nate so this is fresh
dental breast spray so to get rid of
doggie breath not for you humans even
though i think you could try it this is
for your pets so so many things featured
here and we know how important our pets
are right especially during copeth so
many people got dogs and cats and things
like that for companionship and also us
millennials i hate to say it but us
millennials we treat our animals like
our babies because we're not having
anything right so i'm joined by mike
harsting so tell us what are you all
seeing um now again with the increase of
people getting pets millennials spending
more money on their pets yeah 100
this is the first trade show in almost
two years so this is the place for uh
retailers to come and find those new
products just like you said they have a
new dog a new cat at home they have a
new kid they have to come into the to
the pet store and find these new
products and so that's what the
retailers are looking for they've been
in tent up for two years there's a lot
of new products they need to get their
hands on yeah and we've been able to see
a little bit of them we saw the the eye
clean dog wash where you heard arnold
schwarzenegger talking to you and
telling you how to wash your dog so you
all have a little bit of everything tell
us some of the highlights this year that
the pet professionals are going to see
great so not only all the new products
but we have a grooming contest where
professional groomers compete for almost
35 000 in cash
the new products showcase we have 70
hours of education so they're furthering
you know their career
one of the highlights is john taffer's
our keynote speaker from bar rescue and
he's from right here from las vegas that
is incredible so many things featured
here and again this is not opened up to
the public this is going to be your pet
professionals coming here to get these
items and bring them straight to you so
also again just some any other products
that you want to highlight that are
going to be featured here as well we
have everything from
dog food all the way to high tech stuff
like the dog wash that you saw collars
anything you can imagine for your pet is
here and i wouldn't want to highlight
one there are millions
for sure of course you know these
convention centers are so big we've
walked all the way through and there's
something for everybody even cbd
products for cats and dogs they need to
chill out sometimes too so of course
we're going to show you some more coming
up in the next half hour we're going to
send it back to you guys in the studio